[Music]
yesterday's keynote we heard all about
modernization with Google Cloud today's
keynote took us a step further focusing
on infrastructure insight and innovation
director of cloud AI strategy and
operations Tracy Feith is here with us
to tell us more Tracy give us the
highlights from today's keynote so I
think one of the most exciting things is
that we're really starting to see how
customers are leveraging the cloud and
building cloud strategy no matter where
they're starting whether that's starting
from on-prem hybrid all of these things
are now available and we as an overall
cloud organization have been working
really hard to make it incredibly easy
for customers to start where they are
and leverage our products and services
to really update their infrastructure
and drive innovation for their companies
that was really clear to me today and it
was really exciting to see it all come
together now ai is embedded in
everything we do what are you most
excited for about AI and Google cloud
and other parts of Google you know it's
a little bit of a similar answer to be
honest so over the last year and a half
I've spoken with hundreds of customers
and everybody is really excited about AI
but a lot of organizations don't know
what that means and they don't know how
AI can impact their business and the
business problems that they're facing
today and we've been working really hard
to create a set of products and
solutions and services that can help
address some of those mission-critical
problems very easily for customers and
so I'm really excited to see some of
those examples really start to come to
light things like Salesforce working
with Hulu on our contact center our
natural language processes being a part
of the Einstein bot you know things like
what Baker Hughes ge is doing with our
cloud AI platform it's really exciting
to see these tactical examples of how AI
can impact an enterprise absolutely we
saw a lot of great demos showing Google
cloud products at work how are these new
products helping our customers manage
data reliably and securely so they can
modernize scale and and really be
successful if you look at what we saw in
the smart analytics demo you could
really see the end-to-end experience for
customers and that's a lot of where the
pain has been so for example in cloudy I
we own Kaggle which is the world's
largest community of data scientists and
they often joke that data scientists
will say that 90% of the pain and
machine learning is cleaning the data
and 10% is complaining about cleaning
the data and that is an experience that
I think anybody who has worked to
extract insights from their data can
relate to because it can be
extraordinarily painful and when you see
all of the products that are coming
together across our smart analytics
platform everything from bigquery and
data fusion all of those pieces auto ml
tables you can start to see how easy it
can be for customers to extract those
insights at scale very quickly and
speaking of these features that help our
data analytics workflows we saw some
great demos highlighting some new
features like cloud data fusion bakeware
EBI engine and auto ml tables how can
developers scientists and analysts apply
these to support their hybrid workloads
so I can speak specifically to Auto ml
tables because that's the product that
our team works on and one of the things
that I have really loved about the Auto
ml suite is that it really doesn't
require machine learning expertise to
use it and at the same time it's an
extraordinarily helpful tool for people
who are machine learning experts and
builders and
it has the ability to stretch across
those populations and make it really
useful for anybody we have heard over
and over that structured data is a real
challenge for customers and so being
able to leverage something like auto ml
tables where customers can start to
piece together information from
disparate data sets build them all
together allow machine learning models
to be created for you through the auto
ml tool without having to write any code
it just is really exciting to see what
that can do absolutely can you give us
some examples from today's keynote of
how our viewers will be able to use
machine learning and Google i/o
especially those in companies just
starting out who may not already have a
lot of ml experience yeah absolutely
so there are a couple problems that
we've heard from customers that are
really common across the landscape of
enterprise
a top one is in contact centers and
customer service and this is a challenge
that almost every organization I've
spoken with faces in some form or
fashion Rai has worked really hard to
enhance the human agents who are working
in contact centers give them everything
they need at their fingertips in a
really efficient and beautiful way and
what we've done there is integrate our
AI with the key players in the contact
center space so that it doesn't require
customers to do a full rip and replace
on hardware they've already purchased
and so that's a very easy way to get
started we've also heard from almost
every customer that another area that
they really struggle with is dark data
and that exists in documents that are
both physical documents digital
documents the challenge if you can you
know if you think about a paper that you
read or a PDF where you have graphs and
tables and all kinds of information and
the the ability to actually be able to
extract those pieces those components
using AI make sense of them and then
pull insights out of that through our
document understanding AI we really
believe is going to help customers gain
efficiency and information much faster
and that's another way that I think
would be great for customers to get
started that we've seen today know many
people may know that we build AI into a
lot of our products like G suite Google
Maps how can our customers use those
tools to build their innovative features
into their own tools and products so we
offer a range of products everywhere
from pre trained api's to auto emelle's
where you can customize to meet your
specific needs through to our code AI
platform where you can very easily build
your own machine learning models if you
have that expertise and so across that
range there's an opportunity for
customers to really be able to leverage
the power of Google AI in almost every
business problem they face and that can
be very exciting and it can be a little
bit daunting if you don't know exactly
where to get started and so we are
offering a number of solutions through
things like our professional services
organization for customer
who aren't sure where to start we can
help them and then we have a series of
demos of tools all kinds of information
that you can gather to really help you
figure out where AI can help make your
business better
so was the director of AI strategy is
there anything you can tell us about
what we can look forward to in the near
future that's a great question so I
think you know what's top of mind for me
is all of the ways that we can make AI
easier for companies to use how we can
help them scale their businesses and so
you know we are spending a lot of time
in in really building that ease of use
into everything we offer another area
that you will likely start to see from
us is continuing our efforts around
explain ability so I've really firmly
believe that in order for AI to be
successful it really has to be trusted
and in order for it to be trusted it has
to be built and deployed and thought of
responsibly and part of that is about
understanding what is in those machine
learning models and how they're making
decisions and so we have a lot of
exciting efforts around explain ability
and interpret ability yes I mean Trust
is such an important feature and all the
things that we do that's right Tracy
thank you so much for helping us
understand the power of AI to improve
our work you're so welcome glad to be
here
[Music]